Michael Dobbs author of saboteurs the
Nazi raid on America why a book now
about this subject well when I first
discovered the story I thought it was
such an incredible yarn it's the the
very idea of eight Nazi saboteurs coming
to America
six months after America entered the war
by u-boat then they were tried by
military tribunal
there was a historic Supreme Court
session finally they were executed and
that seemed so improbable to me when I
first heard of it that I wanted to write
a story about it but then I was also
attracted by the huge amount of archival
material available I went down to the
National Archives there are whole
shelves of boxes of FBI material going
into great detail about every move they
made and finally after I began the
research 9/11 happened and I immediately
saw a lot of parallels between the way
the u.s. responded to this case and the
way they responded the government
responded to 9/11 when did you first get
the first a little bit of information
that suggested there was new stuff to be
talked about here as soon as I looked in
the FBI archives and the this was one of
the FBI's biggest cases and one of
Hoover's greatest what he considered his
greatest triumphs so all their material
is preserved in the National Archives
but what got you there though in the
first place I'd been researching other
books had researched a book about the
collapse of communism I was a
correspondent in Moscow and then I did a
biography of Madeleine Albright that had
me spending quite a bit of time at the
National Archives so I talked to the
archivists and one of them kindly took
me behind the scenes to where they have
the stacks of files and I actually saw
the all the FBI materials including the
materials on the Nazi saboteurs and -
and just the sheer amount of materials
made it very interesting to me - to do
research on that when I come back there
in a moment
but the year
day of the first landing of Nazi
saboteurs in this country that you're
talking about was when was June 13th
1942 about six months after Pearl Harbor
where did they land they let well there
were two groups two u-boats came across
the Atlantic and the first group landed
in Amagansett Long Island on June 13th
and the second group landed six days
later June 19th Ponte Vedra Florida how
many of them there were four in each
group actually there had been more but a
couple of them dropped out for various
reasons one dropped out on just before
his u-boat was meant to depart from the
port of Lorien in France which was the
German submarine port he decided the
mission was he thought it was going to
fail he he pretended that he had a case
of VD and he he dropped out that was
another new detail that I discovered in
the FBI archives what was their purpose
well the purpose was from Hitler's point
of view it was quite a intelligent
response to America coming into the war
Hitler didn't fear an immediate u.s.
invasion the u.s. armed forces were at
that time pretty ill-prepared certainly
no match for the German army but what he
correctly feared was the long-term
implications of America coming into the
war this huge industrial par with the
ability to churn out huge numbers of
tanks and airplanes so he figured that
he needed to somehow sabotage America's
ability to make war and the target he
chose was the aluminum production
aluminum was used to make airplanes so
the primary target a primary goal of
these saboteurs was to sabotage aluminum
factories around America and disrupt the
production of aluminum the secondary
goal was to disrupt transportation
around the country in June of 1942 where
was the war Talon vall were we
we were involved but not in Europe we
were involved in in mainly in Asia there
was the Battle of the Midway had just
taken place
Pearl Harbor of course had taken place
Guadalcanal was taking place as
simultaneously with the events in this
book and how how many American ships had
been blown up by the Nazis at that point
yeah that was another thing that was
happening that the u-boat war was going
on in the Atlantic up and down the
American coast and German u-boats were
having a field day because America was
really unprepared for this u-boat war
and this I think is one of the parallels
with the situation here before 9/11
there's a kind of false sense of
security that even though America had
entered the war in America itself
nothing much had changed and cities
along the coast for example were very
resistant to imposing blackout
regulations Miami thought that the the
city of Miami refused to impose a
blackout because it thought it would be
bad for tourism
so German u-boats were able to patrol up
and down the coast which was lit up by
the light from cities which was a
perfect backdrop for providing
silhouettes of the targets so the first
few months of 1942 they sank dozens of
dozens of ships all up and down the
American coastline had there been loss
of life a lot of well quite a bit of
loss of life I'm era never a ship goes
down then you know several hundred
sailors can be killed and dozens I I
think I put the precise number in the
book but certainly dozens of ships had
been sunk in that period
what about landings on American Coast
had there been any before this this was
the this was the first one there were a
couple subsequently but this remained
the largest the largest American German
effort to put insert saboteurs into
America now when you set out to write
this book by the way what when was it
what good year what time it was actually
just before 9/11 I began getting
interested in the case in the summer of
2001 and I agreed with my publisher
kenapa to write a book in the summer of
2001
but I didn't really seriously start the
research until 2002 and I wrote the book
in 2002 so if we'd have followed you
around places you went in order to get a
feel for everything where'd you go well
I began here in Washington at the
archives which was the National Archives
which are located in College Park
Maryland which is essential first stop
particularly researching this book
because it's the location of the FBI
files which were extraordinary rich and
although I used other sources that that
was the most helpful to me but having
gone through the entire FBI file I then
more or less followed in the footsteps
of the saboteurs themselves I went to
Amagansett
I saw was able to recreate for myself
the events on the night of their landing
I went to New York of course where they
traveled to soon after landing at M
against it I went another group went to
Chicago I went to Chicago then with the
help of the FBI files that I already had
the FBI FBI was actually following a
couple of the saboteurs around Chicago
so I was able to use that follow
precisely where they had been in Chicago
over the course of a week I went to here
in this country I went to Hyde Park
President Roosevelt's retreat up in
upstate New York where he took the
decision to establish military tribunals
then abroad I went to Hitler's bunker
which is now in Poland in what used to
be East Prussia and woods in the forest
there it was actually the the place
where the attempt on Hitler's life was
made a couple of years after the events
in my book and it was where Hitler took
the decision to mount this sabotage
campaign against the United States and
in Germany I visited the
a little town called Brandenburg which
is about half an hour's train ride from
Berlin where they were trained in the
arts in in sabotage techniques prior to
getting on the u-boat to come to America
almost everybody I mentioned that I was
reading this book knew about this
incident is do you have new stuff in
here that no one's ever seen well
there's a lot of new stuff and there's a
lot of new detail and I think that's the
I mean that's for me the that the main
thing about writing this book was to
discover all this detail I mean we know
the broad outlines of the story but the
what makes the book such a rich story
for a writer is is all the detail
provided by the by the FBI for example
the night they landed in Amagansett the
submarine that brought them over was got
stranded on it on a sandbar a couple of
hundred yards from the beach actually
they landed right next to a Coast Guard
Station of all that places in Amagansett
and the u-boat was stranded on sandbar
it was a foggy night so the people on
the beach the coastguard couldn't see
the u-boat but they could hear it and it
was stranded there for about four hours
and I found the u-boat logs which
described the panic inside the boat as
they tried to get away they were sure
they were certainly were going to be
discovered but the the coastguard never
thought to you know sent about to
investigate these sort of noises of
diesel engines trying to escape so that
was that was one new discovery but there
are many other I got the sense though in
reading acknowledgments and all that
that there might have been some guy out
the archives that said mr. Dobbs come
right over here and said it's all right
there was one of those moments
not exactly somebody did show me as I
said the took me to the area where the
the stacks which is where all these
boxes of material
are held and you know looking at those
files I immediately wanted to look at
them I don't think anybody had really
been through them systematically
beforehand quite a bit of attention had
been paid to the transcript of the
military tribunal proceedings and that
those became that became public 20 30
maybe 3040 years ago but the FBI files
they didn't think anybody had really and
they were only Declassified about five
years ago
so no nobody had really systematically
gone through them
what does u---boat stand for my German
is not all that good I think it's into
boat which means literally a submarine a
boat that goes under the water how big
was it these have these two submarines
they're about the each boat was about
the length of two subway cars and very
thin and very crowded with food
provisions torpedoes all kinds of
equipment so they're incredibly cramped
inside they're about 40 or 50 crew plus
the four saboteurs and you couldn't sort
of move along the u-boat in order to
move along move from one end of the
u-boat to the other people would have to
get out to one side and there's also
kind of delicate system of balancing the
things so too many people couldn't be at
the front or the back
they've sort of very cramped and pretty
delicate delicate pieces of equipment
how fast would those boats travel
they're very slowly they travel I say
they the the normal speed was about the
speed of a bicycle so imagine somebody
taking a bicycle across the Atlantic
they travel above water below water for
the most part they traveled above water
I mean so submarine is kind of a the
wrong term they're really a submersible
I mean they could that they needed to
travel on top of the water to recharge
their Diesel's diesel engines or to
charge their electric motors and to
charge their batteries
and they needed to do that most of the
time and then they could submerge and be
pawed with electric power but most of
the time the in order to make any speed
at all they had to travel on top of the
water so then you go underneath the
water when they're in danger or when
they're about to mount an attack do I
remember it be 12 14 knots above water
about two and a half knots below water I
think that's right yes and how much
below water did they travel on and
either either one of these subs coming
over to this country I'd say about a
quarter of the time they were below
water the eight men that came ashore for
an Amagansett Long Island and four down
at Ponte Vedra Beach in Florida near
Jacksonville were what background how
many of them were Americans well they
were all German Americans and they all
came out of a movement called the German
American Bund which was the American
equivalent of the Nazi Party
they all had similar backgrounds they
had been born in Germany there just
before the First World War in most cases
then after the war they fled or their
parents their families fled Germany
because the economic conditions were
terrible came to America looking for new
opportunities then there was a
depression in America so it wasn't a
great time to to find jobs in America so
many of them had failed in America in
different ways so when Hitler came to
power in Germany they were then for
different reasons attracted by Hitler
thought they wanted to go back to
Germany support Germany in in in in the
war that was just beginning so they all
having been in America become
disillusioned with America for some
reason then went back to Germany where
because they had a knowledge of America
and spoke varying degrees of English
they were selected for this mission this
sabotage mission you've got some
pictures in I want to show some of them
because I don't want you to tell us
about some of these folks who is the guy
they're on job well he was the leader of
the expedition his name is George John -
and he had been a waiter in in the
United States he was had failed in
practically everything he did he had
been a traveling salesman he failed at
that he failed as a waiter he had
dabbled with communism then became
interested in Nazism and but he did have
an intimate knowledge of American ways
he had a kind of slang knowledge of
English and knew a lot about American
popular culture of baseball which was
one of the reasons that made him
attractive to to the people who
organized this expedition which boat was
he on he was on the first boat the u 202
which landed in in Amagansett Long
Island who's this fellow down here below
his name is Edward curling and he was
much more committed Nazi than George -
he was the leader of the second group
that landed in Ponte Vedra Florida and
of all the eight saboteurs he was the
most ideologically committed to the Nazi
cause and he was the most likely to
carry out some kind of sabotage attacks
in the United States did either one of
these men have relatives here in this
country they did for example Curling had
a wife not only a wife he also had a
mistress here and as soon as he got back
here he started trying to make contacts
with his with his family and his friends
a matter of fact the last pictures you
have in your book down here who's this
this these two women at the bar that is
the on the left you see a big anchorman
who's the was the mistress of Eddie
curling and on the right is his wife
Marie how much of this fact that there
was a mistress and a wife played in the
story at all well he traveled to New
York and one of the things he did he had
a very complicated so just suggested it
was a he had a very complicated marital
situation so even though he had been
seeing
the mistress by that stage she decided
he wanted to go back to the wife and in
addition to the sabotage operation that
was one of the things he wanted to
resolve in his trip to the United States
he wanted to make up with the wife so he
was in the process actually when he came
to New York of seeing the mistress and
seeing the wife and trying to get back
together with the wife so he also even
though despite his intense Nazi
convictions he also had personal reasons
for coming to America and this man mr.
Berger here who is he he was Dash's
number two in the group that landed in
Amagansett he's an interesting person he
joined the Nazi Party in the early 20s
he was one of the participants in the
Munich Beer Hall Putsch say he was one
of Hitler's earliest followers had been
a member of the Nazi Party from very
early on but he sided with some of
Hitler's opponents so he kind of fell
out with the with Nazi Party
establishment and at one point actually
spent some time in German prison camp so
he came back he was selected to this
mission for this mission as a way of
redeeming himself and rehabilitating
himself but he harbored this secret
grudge against against the Nazis which
later became important there are two
things that you mentioned the book I
want to ask you to explain one was the
Munich Beer Hall Putsch 1933 no no in
the early 20th 2008 I think they yeah 33
is a year that Hitler became it that
hidden became chanced and there was the
light night of the Long Knives in which
Hitler murdered or killed had had killed
many of the supporters of aunts Rome who
was the head of the SA the sort of Nazi
street thugs and that was the night of
the Long Knives which would have what we
are was there I think that's in 1933 32
33
when she was 4 what was it the put the
the munich munich there yeah
well that was when hitler tried to seize
power in the in bavaria and in munich
but the bavarian capital it was a kind
of failed attempt to seize power as a
result of which hitler was arrested went
to prison and so it was kind of
preliminary attempt by the nazis to
seize part but the people who were at
Hitler's side including burger during
the during the Munich Beer Hall Putsch
Worth's that are considered the original
core membership of the Nazi Party what's
the average age of these eight that came
ashore here they all did their range
from the youngest is about twenty
twenty-two and the oldest was about
forty who is this that is Heinrich Hank
he was one of the less distinguished
members of the of the group that landed
in Amagansett he'd been a Volkswagen
member a member of the German American
worker for Volkswagen and a member of
the German American Bund he was a
essentially a follower rather than a
leader and the fellow next to him up top
that's happy helped he's an interesting
person he he was the youngest of the
saboteurs he'd been brought up in
Chicago was the most Americanized of all
of them he had left Chicago at the
beginning of the war because he fell out
with his girlfriend he made his
girlfriend pregnant and he essentially
ran off to Mexico I call him the
accidental cemetery because he fell into
this plot quite by chance he ran round
he went around the world he ended up in
Nazi Germany because he couldn't get
back to America as soon as he got to
Germany he immediately sort of dreamed
of getting back to America somehow and
this mission was offered him a chance to
get back to America that he kind of fell
into the fell into the
plot by accident show the others in a
moment but which u-boat landed first the
u-boat and I'm against it and what was
the difference in time for the second
boat that landed in Florida that's six
days later how long did it take them to
transverse the Atlantic about three
weeks they left from what tort they left
from the port of Lorien which is on the
western seaboard of the Atlantic
seaboard of France France by that time
had fallen under Nazi control so Lorien
was one of the mains submarine ports
that the Germans had on the Atlantic
coast and from where they they launched
many of their missions across the
Atlantic did Hitler know about this
about this precise mission yes he
certainly knew he had approved the the
plan I'm not sure how many of the
details he actually knew but he had
approved the sabotage plan personally
against the United States in a meeting
that he had with the leaders of German
military intelligence in his bunker in
East Prussia that I visited I noticed in
the back of the book that you'd author
interviews included this man and I got
the sense that he might still be alive
is he he is yeah he lives in Virginia on
the Chesapeake his name is John Callen
and in 1942 he was a very young member
of the US Coast Guard
he was stationed at Amagansett and on
the night of June 13th 1942 when the
u-boat landed he had the he was what was
known as a sand pounder the at the
beginning of the war Roosevelt insisted
that some kind of rudimentary coastal
defense be instituted so they had coast
guards along the entire seaboard
patrolling the the coastline they were
they were unarmed they they patrolled
alone so they were not really prepared
for anybody coming ashore that and it
took them sort of they had
each had a route that they had followed
two miles out and two miles back
so Cullen was the Coast Guard that night
at Amagansett who was on patrol when the
saboteurs landed and amazingly he
actually ran into - on this foggy
incredibly dark night it was a moonless
night of June 13th when they landed what
did they carry with him what kind of a
secretary yes they had come they were
dressed in kind of rudimentary Nazi
German army uniforms because they
thought that if they were intercepted on
landing that the the uniforms would give
them some kind of protection that they
would be arrested not as saboteurs but
as soldiers and they brought with them
each four boxes of sabotage gear very
pretty sophisticated sabotage equipment
you know bomb-making equipment fuses
detonators liable to do quite a bit of
damage is it still there I mean is it
did you find this or just this picture
was there that's the picture of four of
the boxes of sabotage gear that were
unearthed from Ponte Vedra Beach I
didn't find that the equipment is no
longer in the archives oh I never got to
the archives I imagine it's in the
basement of the FBI summer I don't know
what happened to the equipment itself
then that's not there a lot of other
things in the archives but not the
precise equipment when they landed on
Amagansett by the way how far out on
Long Island is now far from New York
City do you have to drive to get to him
again sir it's about two hours by car
from from New York City so it's pretty
near the tip of Long Island any marker
there by the way that says that they
landed there not in Amagansett there
isn't Ponte Vedra Beach there's a market
identifying the spot and in fact there's
some controversy over exactly where the
spot is in Amagansett there was never as
a precise location made I think I pretty
much identified it but it's about a mile
from
the coastguard station used to be but
it's it's not identified what time of
day did they put in they did the sub and
and how did the sub get into this the
shore
well the sub had been submerged and it's
sort of it came to the surface it so
edged its way into the shore and as soon
as they felt that there was sand beneath
them they knew they were pretty close to
the shore they're deliberately chosen a
moonless night because they wanted you
know to beat the stock as possible for
obvious reasons having but what they
didn't know was there bumped into a kind
of false sandbar which is actually
notoriously Amagansett there'd be many
shipwrecks on this sandbar
so having having bumped into the sandbar
they then got a rubber dinghy the four
saboteurs got into the dinghy and rowed
ashore from the dinghy it was very
pretty stormy night so they got drenched
on the ways they landed completely
drenched and rather disorientated in the
meantime the the u-boat had had swung
around so that the entire boat was sort
of beat during during the operation of
putting the saboteurs onto the dinghy
they hadn't paid enough attention to
what was happening to the u-boat itself
and it's swung around and got stranded
on the sand stuck on the sandbar
was there any communications and by the
way was interesting to learn that that
captain of the boat was like 29 years
old right all the u-boat skipper's were
were pretty young people and it was the
very high mortality rate and they are
higher than in in the German u-boat
service than in any other military unit
on either side practically I think so
so all the I mean the the captain was 29
years old most of the crew were about 21
22 he was considered an old man I've got
one it's just the captain of the that's
the cat again sent both of the
Amagansett boat 29 years old 29 right by
the way what happened - he was later
like many u-boat captains he
as his boat was sunk and he was killed
during the war could they communicate
from the boat back to Germany they could
they had to come to the surface in order
to communicate there was one reason why
they why they had to frequently come to
the surface and the US and Britain were
able to track these communications and
more or less get a pretty good idea of
where the u-boats were through these
communications and at one point they
were able to decipher the communications
through the the the communications were
coded with a help of a machine called
enigma and the Allies found a way of
deciphering this actually at the precise
moment when these seven these people
landed that was at a time when this
window was closed so at that particular
time the Allies didn't have the ability
to decipher the communications but they
could locate the boats by triangulating
where the radio signals were coming from
who are some of the other members of
this the two crews that's Richard
quieren he was one of the foursome that
landed in Amagansett he'd also worked
for Volkswagen being a member of the
German American Bund but fellow down
here in the middle that's vanity oh he
was a member of the of the Florida group
another I think he'd also worked for
Volkswagen when he went back to the
United Germany and finally Hermann Lloyd
Bauer he was a member of Dash's group
that landed in Amagansett he had been
wounded on on the Russian front pretty
severely he had sort of chunks of metal
in his head he was extremely nervous
about coming back to the United States
probably the most nervous of all the of
all of all those cemeteries how much did
John Cullen remember how old is he now
he's he was 22 then and this was about
60 just over 60
oh so he's now in his early 80s he's
he's got a pretty sharp memory of it I
spent an afternoon with him in his house
that's him just outside his front door
and of course you know he's told the
story many times and in his role is
limited to the 15 minutes or so when
he's spent on the beach but you know
those 15 minutes imprinted on his mind
but the Germans had declared war we'd
declared war on them both ways this was
1942 in the middle of the year and we
didn't have any real defenses up to that
or any thought that they really would
come ashore we didn't take the threat I
mean perhaps in theory there was the the
people talked about the possibility of
saboteurs landing but until this
happened it wasn't taken very seriously
actually one of the few people who took
it seriously was FDR because Roosevelt
had been assistant Navy secretary during
the First World War and he was kind of
aficionado for spy stories and he
thought there was a real threat and he
tried to beef up the Coast Guard he
tried he'd for example walkie-talkies
had just been introduced and he'd seen
his Secret Service people at Hyde Park
and in Washington what talking using
walkie-talkies to communicate so he
thought it would be a good idea if these
two-way radios were also issued to the
sand pounders the coast guards and he
made the suggestion a few months before
the saboteurs landed but nobody took him
up on this it was sort of one of the
suggestions from the commander in chief
that people just ignored so the four
that came in at Amagansett ended up
going where they haven't got off the
beach
they ran into Cullen on the beach and he
went back to summon help and by the time
that he came back there disappeared they
had moved inland where did they go they
went to Amagansett rail station and the
first train into new york was the six
o'clock
morning well they landed at one o'clock
and they got to the rail station at four
o'clock and the first thing they did was
to they had lots of money with them they
had about a hundred thousand dollars the
equivalent of about a million dollars
today so had no trouble paying the fare
they just took the first train that came
along which took them into into
Manhattan by the way six days later when
the book went into Ponte Vedra Beach in
Florida where did they go they have any
trouble at all anybody catch them at all
no they they had much less trouble than
the than the emigrant Gansett group
they're landing went off pretty smoothly
they buried their sabotage equipment and
they took a bus into Jacksonville which
is not precisely on the coastline it's
about 30 40 minutes away and they
checked into Jacksonville hotels
just as the Amagansett group checked
into and they arrived at Penn Station
and they checked into the hotel just
across the street from the Penn Station
The New Yorker it's not The New Yorker
it's I forget the name but it's still
there it's a different it's it's it has
a different name now but it's right
opposite the train station so then we
know they were caught how long did it
take and how did it done unravel that
they were eventually caught well they
having landed and there's a question of
whether when - the leader of the
immigrant group decided - decided to
betray the rest of them and turn himself
in to the FBI but he and Berger called
the FBI the night after they arrived and
he said that his name was mr. Pistorius
the operation by the way was called
Operation Pistorius after the first
German settlers who came to me came to
America in the 17th century but he
called the FBI in New York and said his
name is mr. Pistorius he just arrived by
u-boat from him from Germany and he had
some very important news
nation to impart J Edgar Hoover and he
was dismissed as a crank they they
thought that he was a lunatic and they
made a note of the conversation but they
didn't do anything about it and then a
few days later - took the train down to
Washington checked into the Mayflower
Hotel here in Washington and the next
morning walked into or called FBI
headquarters and was brought to FBI
headquarters where he began telling his
story why do you want to do this where
he says that he had become totally
disillusioned with Nazism by the time he
soon after he went he returned to
Germany and that he secretly hated
Hitler and had decided to do it all
along that he wanted to use the money
that they'd been given for the operation
to mount a propaganda campaign against
Hitler using American radio facilities
so that was his dream that he would use
this money to through buy broadcasts on
American radio awaken the German people
to the evil of both Hitler and that was
how long after they landed that was when
he went into the FBI in Washington that
was about a week after they landed so
simultaneously the other that was about
the same time almost simultaneously with
the landing of the group in Ponte Vedra
and - said that he wait he was asked why
he waited so long to go to the FBI and
one of his reasons was that he wanted to
give the Ponte Vedra group the Florida
group the chance of also turning
themselves in that he wouldn't just
betray them without at least giving them
the same chance that he had had of going
to the FBI where did the Ponte Vedra
group go that two of them went to New
York including curling the the leader of
the group who had had his wife and
mistress both living in New York and the
other two went to Chicago Herbie helped
hood lived in Chicago had been brought
up in Chicago he went back and the first
thing he did was just he had many
friends and
he had family in Chicago and so he just
resumed the life he'd led before the war
of course he had a lot of money in his
pocket so he was able to have a much
able to have a good time he actually
bought a car in Chicago at one point and
he had parents there his parents his
uncle's relations where did Cincinnati
come in and all this
Cincinnati was the place where they when
they got the train to Chicago they
changed trains in Cincinnati one group
went in New York and the other group
went to Chicago and they also had a plan
to or for both groups to meet up in
Chicago on July 4th that having made
their landings the initial plan was that
the two groups would come together in
Cincinnati or the leaders of the two
groups had come together in Cincinnati
on July 4th and begin to put into
operation the air sabotage plane a
surprise how often you said in the book
that these one of these guys would tell
their friends they just came in on a
submarine and they were on a sabotage
mission why would they tell all these
people this well they tell people they
trusted and they tried to hide it I mean
- was sort of naturally extremely
talkative so on the one hand he was
mysterious about how exactly he'd got
back to America I mean he was a
well-known figure in New York waders
circles in fact one of the things he did
when he went to New York was that he he
went to the waiters Club in New York and
has annexed was a fiend for Pinocchio
which is is it Pinocchio Pinocchio
pinochle peanuts right pinochle he he
loved playing pinochle and he had a two
and a half day game using some of the
money he'd brought over with him to
gamble on pick on on pinochle he played
it for two and a half days that is
non-stop and during that period he was
obviously under quite a bit of
for stress but he led out to some of his
waiters friends that he had come back on
a submarine of course nobody believed it
yeah another man you talked to is a man
named Wayne Trainor right and here's a
picture of him where did you find him
well he lives in Springfield Illinois
and he's in his early 90s but he still
has an incredibly precise memory and he
was the FBI agent the head of the FBI's
anti Cybertron's unit who was the first
FBI man
in the United States to interview to
interview - so when - arrived at the
Mayflower Hotel he called the FBI
again this is his second call to the FBI
he asked to be spoken he asked to speak
to Hoover and Hoover's office put him in
charge put him in touch with the next
person down the hierarchy and after
about three or four people he finally
got to speak to Traynor who was the
first person to take him seriously and
said I'll send a car right over for you
so he went over to the FBI and began
telling his story now I know he talked
to him for a long time but one of the
stranger things I learned in your book
was the trainer ended up moving into his
hotel room and the Mayflower Hotel here
in Washington and stayed in the room
with him for how many nights he stayed
just one night but trainers assistance
stayed the the other nights it took -
four or five days to tell his entire
story and the transcript of his
confession is about five hundred pages
long he was just sitting in the in
trainer's office as teams of
stenographers took down his story and at
that time the FBI treated him very
respectfully and they treated him as a
free man so instead of putting him in
you know in a jail cell after at the end
of each interrogation session they
permitted him to go back to the hotel
and the first night trainer went back
with him to the hotel and though it was
about midnight they got back to the
hotel and
the before they went to bed I guess
there were twin beds in the in the hotel
room - told trainer he said I've got
something to show you and he brought out
his suitcase and produced about a
hundred thousand American dollars which
was China told me was more money than
he'd ever seen in his life and it was
sort of one of the things that convinced
him that - was telling the truth the
five hundred page transcript had that
been published before most of a lot of
that had come out during the military
tribunal hearings because - insisted
that his entire confession be read into
the record so that transcript was was
available before years I want to read a
paragraph he wrote in page 87 and it and
get your background on it the sense of
American invulnerability was reflected
in the low priority placed on Homeland
Security
this is 1942 the defense's set up along
the eastern seaboard and the immediate
aftermath of America's entry into the
war were scanty and improvised in the
words of the Army's official history
they were strengthened somewhat in April
as a result of the growing u-boat menace
and intelligence reports that Germans
might be trying to land saboteurs along
the coast here's what I want to ask you
about but there were many glaring holes
caused in large part by bureaucratic
turf fights between the agencies
responsible for homeland security sound
familiar
very familiar this is 1942 is 42 right
there were and then you end up a show a
picture of the man you end up talking a
lot about and what he did in this whole
this whole story J Edgar Hoover and his
his aide there Clyde Tolson who are
buried about three but three feet from
each other out in the a congressional
cemetery here in Washington well Jack
Hoover was his extraordinary person he
built the FBI up into a remarkable
organization but he was also vicious
bureaucratic in fighter and he was
determined that he and the FBI would
take the credit for breaking the case he
hoarded information and he refused to
let any FBI agents in
other government agencies there was
vicious bureaucratic infighting between
the FBI and other government agencies
all of which you can follow in the in in
the files particularly vicious with the
Coast Guard and Naval Intelligence and
at one point things got so bad that they
were leaking rival stories to the press
as the military tribunal was going on
the Coast Guard wanted to they wanted to
take the credit they saw this as a the
fact that their man John Cullen had ran
into the saboteurs on the beach was
something they wanted to be made public
and they thought that had led to the
unraveling of the case data
Hoover was contemptuous of the way that
Coast Guard had allowed the sabotage
sabotage to get away and he he thought
they were completely incompetent and
didn't want to give any credit to the
Coast Guard at all
so he had a PR guy called Lou Nichols
who was probably the I made Hoover's
reputation and he had a lot of contacts
in the media and he strong-armed the
Coast Guard into into keeping quiet
in fact he sort of threatened the Coast
Guard he said that if you bring out your
side of the story
we will have to for the sake of he put
it in a kind of plight way he said that
you wouldn't want all this unpleasant
information about the Coast Guard to
become public would you the fact that
you allowed the saboteurs to get away
from the beach so you see and one of the
reasons that I was interested in this
case as a journalist is that you know we
journalists don't get to see what's
actually happening in the bureaucracies
we don't read the memos but 60 years
later you can read the memos and one of
the things that we find when we do read
these internal documents is that the
infighting can become pretty vicious
well another parallel with today are
these tribunals that happen back there
when it was there a public announcement
that these eight men had been caught
Hoover made the announcement just after
about a week after
- walked into the FBI headquarters in
Washington it took them a week to round
up everybody else and at that point
Hoover made his own announcement that
they had been caught and that disturbed
a lot of other people in the government
the military intelligence the War
Department was furious with Hoover
because they thought it would be much
better if the whole thing was kept
secret and then perhaps other teams of
German saboteurs would come over here
and they could roll them all up but by
going public
Hoover prevented that from happening so
that was one of the controversies inside
the government where'd they put the
eight men they took them all by this
time that arrested - that stopped
treating him as a free man they
eventually took them all to jail cells
in the New York FBI headquarters and
then once they decided to hold a
military tribunal they were transferred
to the Army and held in a military Jail
in Washington the military tribunal took
place in the Justice Department building
in Washington yeah they can't they're
caught June they caught they landed in
June 13th they were rounded up within
two weeks of their landing so when were
the tribunals the tribunals began in
July in mid-july
right away so the whole and that's sort
of contrast with what's happening now in
two years after 9/11 and two years after
the Bush administration's announced that
they were going to try al-qaeda people
by military tribunals no tribunals have
yet been held but in this case the whole
legal process was compressed into into
two months the landing the rounding up
for the saboteurs the military tribunals
as a Supreme Court hearing and six of
them were executed all within two months
and the Attorney General tried the
Tribunal for the government and this
picture here he's been right over here
when was this picture
made available to the media well that's
Francis Biddle the who's the Attorney
General and he prosecuted the case
himself because he can trust any of his
subordinates to prosecute it but the
tribunal was held in secret so
journalists weren't allowed into the
tribunal hearing but they made such a
fuss about it that the army agreed to an
exception and did permit them into one
small part of a hearing and that's when
these photographs were taken how long
did the tribunals take they took about
two weeks what happened to this eight
men in the tribunals well the two who
had turned themselves into the FBI -
would actually physically come here to
Washington and he'd done it with the
agreement of Peter Berger he's number
two so they were given that they were
all sentenced to death we'll all eight
of them but then the sentences on Berger
and - were commuted to life imprisonment
how would the six put to death the six
were put to death in the DC jail by the
electric chair how soon after the
Tribunal's decision well there was the
tribunal and then there was a habeas
corpus appeal to the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court ruled against sabotage by
the way the same thing is happening now
that there's a some of the attorneys for
some of the detainees in Guantanamo have
appealed to the Supreme Court based on
the on the 1942 precedent but so there
was the military tribunal Supreme Court
hearing by within a week of the end of
the of the tribunal and the six of them
had been executed so came to the country
and jaren they're dead by August 8th and
you also shown at two months and you
also show that the Supreme Court was
very emotionally involved in this
including Felix Frankfurter the Justice
- they wanted these men to be executed
right I think the Supreme Court had to
festival the the Supreme Court was
divided the Chief Justice stone he
wanted to assert some kind of judicial
authority over the executives so he
thought that the fact that the
government had decided they should be
put on trial by military tribunals that
there should be some kind of challenge
to that so he accepted the habeas corpus
challenge but having done so then the
Supreme Court didn't want to interfere
with the government's handling of the
war and particularly Felix Frankfurter
felt that in time of war there was no
time and little use for getting involved
in constitutional arguments so
frankfurter by the way was pretty
friendly with Stimpson the Secretary of
War so he had decided pretty much from
the outset that they weren't going to
agree to the habeas corpus requests and
partly under frankfurters influence they
rejected these habeas corpus requests
there was two days Supreme Court hearing
and they did something very strange
which was that they rejected the
requests of habeas corpus without
explaining why they were rejecting them
without finding the legal grounds for
the decision the legal grounds were only
published and only agreed upon months
after the saboteurs were executed well
the current justices be dealing with it
on the basis of that decision back then
well this decision is an extremely
important legal precedent yes because up
until then the case that had guided
whether or not military tribunals are
legal was a Civil War era decision
called Mulligan Milligan after the Civil
War the there was appealed to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court then
decided that military tribunals were
illegal as long as civilian courts were
opening were open and functioning and in
1942
the Supreme Court reversed or partially
reversed the Milligan decision and
decided that there were some
circumstances in which military courts
were legal so both sides can actually
draw some both sides in the present
debate can draw some support from the
from the 1942 Supreme Court decision -
and Berger end up going back to Germany
how long they live - they both went were
pardoned by Truman they went back to
Germany in 1948 they - spent much of his
time trying to get back to the United
States he died in 1972 Hoover vetoed all
his attempts to get back to the United
States Berger was on much better terms
with the FBI he was considered much more
trustworthy by Hoover in fact he used to
send Hoover Christmas cards and inform
provide Hoover information about his
fellow Nazis and the last mention of him
that I found in FBI files is the early
60s and then he disappeared nobody knows
what happened to him I help me out here
though I read your book and I'm reading
about this fella - who considers himself
an American he comes over here on the
boat the first thing he does is turn in
all of these people he goes to the FBI
he tells them everything about it
why wouldn't he get some kind of a
pardon why why would they just slap him
in the in jail and then try them and
convict him and sentence him to death
well there were two reasons for that one
was that Hoover wanted to take all the
credit
for rounding up the saboteurs he didn't
want it to be made public that in fact
the reason why the FBI was able to round
up the saboteurs was one of them hadn't
gone and told the whole story to the FBI
so I think there was a personal reason
but there was also a military reason
which is that they didn't want to let
the Germans know why the operation had
failed they wanted to give the Germans
the impression that American coasts were
impregnable and that the FBI was
everywhere and that would be a deterrent
to the Nazis to send further sabotage
teams over to America but the fact was
that as a result of the publicity
surrounding the case the Germans had a
pretty good idea of what had gone wrong
Michel DAWs was born in Belfast Northern
Ireland it says in the back of the book
and educated the University of York with
fellowships at Princeton and Harvard how
did you get into this business into
journalist motivated both well I'd been
a journalist in Britain and I had worked
in many different countries including
Yugoslavia I worked as a freelance in
Yugoslavia and I was very fortunate that
I was in Eastern Europe at the time when
the region was exploding there's in
Poland which I was there when the Lenin
shipyard was occupied by strikers under
leg for winter and I'd been stringing
among other Peter for various newspapers
including the Washington Post and The
Washington Post decided they needed a
correspondent in Warsaw and since I was
on the spot they appointed me how long
have you worked for The Washington Post
since those events in Poland which was
1918 and how long were you in Russia
with them the post I then went to Russia
with them and I was fortunate there
because my time with the post in Moscow
coincided with the extraordinary
Gorbachev reforms and the collapse of
communism and the disintegration of the
Soviet Union and what's your beat now I
now cover American education so I'm
covering this is the first really
American beat that I've had and it's
giving me an opportunity to find out a
little bit about this country and your
next book I am talking to my publisher
cannot for about a book about the Cuban
Missile Crisis we're out of time our
guest has been Michael Dobbs is with the
Washington Post and has written this
book called saboteurs the Nazi raid on
America thank you very much thank you